DANIEL FRIEDMAN: Hello, it's July 28, 2023,
and we're in active inference textbook
group Slash Bookstream 2.02.
Thanks Ali, for joining. So what we're
going to do today is give a short
overview of the chapters from the par at
all 2022 book. We're going to do
chapters four, five, seven,
and eight,
and we're just going to pause between
them because then we'll clip them into
the shorter videos, append that to the
playlist. Just so there's a first video
overview of each of the chapters and
this is the second in that work.
All right, so we'll do
chapter four. We'll just wait a few
seconds and then start chapter four.
Okay, chapter four is called
Degenerative Models of Active Inference,
and it begins with a quotation,
everything should be made as simple as
possible, but not simpler by Albert
Einstein. Ali, what is your overview,
thought or warning for chapter four?
ALI RAHMJOO: Okay, so after the preliminary materials
in chapters two and three,
which was basically largely based on
providing some conceptual framework for
developing the further theory,
chapter four delves into much more
detail in terms of mathematical
formulation. And it unpacks a
lot more the way that the
central equations of active inference is
derived and how to construct the
important elements of active inference
models. So say matrices
A-B-C and D, and also how to put
together generative models in different
situations. So it basically lays
out the foundation constructing
active inference models both for
discrete time situations and continuous
time ones, which will be used
later in chapters seven and eight. But
this is probably one of the most
challenging and at least mathematically
dense chapters in the book. So I would
personally suggest reading through this
chapter really slowly.
And even if we don't get to
understand every single detail of the
chapter, obviously we can return
required as we go through the textbook.
Thank you, Ali. Yes. So let's
look through the sections. Just to add
on, though, chapter four is one of the
larger and more equation dense
chapters because it is the common
kernel or basis that's then going to
get applied in chapter five. In the
Neurobiological case, there's a recipe
for making chapter four in chapter six.
That's the recipe for active inference
modeling. Chapter seven and eight are
about the discrete and the continuous
time variant or subtype or motif of
these kinds of things called generative
models. So this is the real common route
and we'll just look at what the sections
are. This chapter complements the
preceding chapter's conceptual treatment
of active inference with a more formal
treatment. Section 4.2 from Bayesian
inference to free energy. What would you
say about this section, Ali? Okay,
so as we know, the free energy principle
is inspired by previous work
on Bayesian inference, I mean all the
way back to Helmholt's theory
about unconscious inference
or something to that effect. I can't
remember the exact term, but here
it provides in a bit more detail how
we can derive free energy principle
formalism using the established
Bayesian inference formulation.
And particularly one of the key
movements or at least one of the key
decisions through the derivation of free
energy principle formulation is using
Jane's inequality principle to derive an
upper bound instead of just using the
exact values to compute or
to achieve the required parameters.
So that's basically,
in my opinion, the key premise of
section 4.2 and
to see in a bit more detail
how we can achieve those upper
bounds using Jane's inequality directly
by using manipulations of Bayesian
statistical formalism. Thanks.
I'll just add one point from this
section broadly. These are the problems
of inferring states of the world
perception and inferring a course of
action planning. So this is again
referring to the perception and
everything that happens in between is
the internal or the cognitive part of
the inference. But this is like the
blanket state cybernetic input output.
And then let's look at the
first equation or how much equations
overall or what equations do you think
we should highlight?
Okay,
just as a general comment about these
different equations. Well, each of these
equations provide a distinct step toward
deriving the ultimate whole picture.
So even if we don't
quite understand how we can derive from
each step to the other one,
it's good to know that it's only
required to understand how we get to
that ultimate whole picture. But
ultimately what we would need in order
to develop active inference models
is the ultimate equation or ultimate
whole picture. So this is just a
way to elucidate the steps toward
developing that whole picture. But
again, it's not an essential requirement
to understand the materials
of the rest of the book. But if we go
from equations 4.1 toward
the 4.4 or other words, a variational
free energy, well, equation 4.1 is
just a basic definition of some
properties of probabilities in terms of
conditional probability and so on. So
equation 4.2 provides the
central Jane's inequality principle
and how it relates to conditional
probabilities and of course joint
probabilities. And then by using those
two properties or those two equations,
we ultimately get to 4.4,
which is the definition of variation
free energy parameter, which is the
parameter of interest that needs to be
optimized in order to inference to
happen or at least perceptual inference
to happen in active inference models.
Thanks. Only thing I'll add is F is
the letter used for variational free
energy. Think of it like a computer
program and the arguments that it takes
in or the variables that it takes in are
q, which is the distribution that's
under the statistician's control and Y,
which are the data which are outside of
the statistician's control. And do
you want to describe more about anything
in this equation or carry on?
Just one thing that
can probably be helpful is to somehow
compare these steps with the initial
picture we had from chapter two because
variation free energy was first
introduced in chapter two. So it
can be helpful to go back and forth
between chapters two and four and try to
connect the dots between the related
points there.
Section 4.3 generative Models all right,
I'll read the first sentence, then you
can give some thoughts. To calculate the
free energy, we need three things data,
a family of variational distributions
and a generative model comprising a
prior and a likelihood.
In this section, we outlined two very
general sorts of generative model used
for active inference and the form the
free energy takes in relation to each.
Okay, so as mentioned earlier,
this chapter deals both with discrete
time and continuous time situations.
So clearly we would need two different
types of generative models for each
situation. And obviously
the generative models or the way to
construct generative models for discrete
time situations would vary quite a bit
from the one for continuous time
situations. But the
general principle underlying those
generative models are basically the
same, which is to
somehow construct a model of the
environment,
either be it for the situation
that is sequential in time or for the
situations that need to be somehow each
moment of the situation needs to be
accommodated in terms of a continuous
time situation. So Figure
4.2 provides some examples of both.
Let me see. Yes,
so we have some examples
of different kinds of generative models,
some case studies
if you like. And it provides various
ways to show how the dependencies
between variables can be modeled using
these kinds of graphical probabilistic
models. So one common way to represent
generative models is to use these kinds
of graphical probabilistic models in
active inference literature, which is
at least in this case, the circles would
represent the random variables and
the squares would represent the
distributions, which would describe the
dependencies between those random
variables. So we can see
the clear relationships between those
parameters here, which is basically what
this whole graph, what constitutes
the generative model that needs to be
used for different situations. And then
in Figure 4.3,
we can compare the two
different types of generative models
based on whether it's discrete time
or continuous time situations. So the
upper picture is a generative model for
the discrete time situation and the
lower picture is the
parallel continuous time version of it.
And as we can see, the general topology
of these models are the same.
The only things that differ is
the use of parameters for policies
or I mean, discrete time policies or the
continuous time ones. And we can
obviously compare the different elements
for both priors states and
external states, internal states and so
on by comparing these two models
here. Yeah, we often
return to Figure 4.3. It's kind of the
Rosetta Stone of generative modeling
for the context of this book because
it's then going to develop out into
chapter seven and eight. And it
represents a really fundamental decision
made in modeling and in
the later chapters. It's also shown how
it can be made into a hierarchical model
that combines aspects of both, but
within each level of modeling still,
these are the kinds of decisions that
modelers are presented with when it
comes to statistical modeling overall.
So Section 4.4 goes into essentially
the top half of Figure 4.3 discrete
time. What would you say about discrete
time? Okay, so the
discrete time situation is
obviously the archetype discrete time
situation, which is the Palm DP models.
So at this point I would very
much like to recommend following
the material from step by step paper,
because in
that paper, the way to construct Palm DP
models is described in a bit more
detail. So if anyone feels like they
should learn a bit more about the
gaps in the details, I would very much
like to recommend that particular paper.
I don't know how much detail we should
go into because although
it's not maybe detailed enough for some
tastes, but it goes in a quite extensive
detail about how we can construct
these models using the concepts we've
learned in previous chapters.
So ultimately we reach
equations 4.13 and 4.14,
which are basically the culmination of
Palm DP formulation using the vector
notations and gradients and so on.
Then we go to continuous time situation.
Great. A few things intervene
in the continuous time chapter ones that
we'll just mention here because they're
kind of boxed or partitioned
from the continuous time part, but
they're following pages versus Markov
blankets. We won't go into it here, but
kind of footnote that or look at some
other places where we talk about it
outside of this chapter. Overview figure
4.4 Bayesian message passing.
Again, a big topic. Let's kind
of just go past it now back to
the regularly scheduled continuous time
generative model discussion. And then
another box to the generalized
coordinates of motion. So taking
position plus derivatives of position.
And that has some beneficial properties
that are described and unpacked also
elsewhere.
Do you want to say anything about 4.5.2?
Well, the only thing that comes to mind
is although as I said before,
all the formulations here may look
more, I mean, a bit too dense to
understand at the first pass. But some
of the key maybe components
here could be obviously
the material from box 4.2
and 4.3 I
think are quite essential to understand
the underlying principle behind deriving
the continuous time situation because
without LaPlace approximation, what we
would have in terms of free energy
minimization is it would look
very much like the Gibbs free energy.
The key distinction between the
free energy principle as described in
active inference literature, as opposed
to Gibbs free energy is this
distinction, is the LaPlace
approximation. So this is what enables
us to go from Gibbs free energy to
the variation of free energy. So yeah,
that's quite essential to make
this to be familiar with this essential
approximation. And obviously the
concept of generalized coordinates of
motion will come time and time again
throughout the whole book, particularly
in chapters eight and nine.
So, yeah, those two concepts,
I believe, needs a bit more
attention.
Yeah, sounds good. Box 4.3 LaPlace
approximation equations,
another message passing,
representation, and a
summary. The key message to take away is
that approximate Bayesian inference may
be framed as minimizing a quantity known
as variational free energy. This depends
on a generative model that expresses our
belief about how data are generated.
Anything else you want to add?
Ah, nothing comes to mind at the moment
because, as I said,
we're still in the stage
that we want to develop our essential
tools to be used in the rest of the
book. So here, up until now,
I believe by the end of chapter four,
we have acquired all the essential,
necessary mathematical tools.
And the next chapter, chapter five,
kind of acts like an interlude,
and I don't think it's the direct
continuation of chapters one through
four. So I believe the
first part of the book, conceptually and
mathematically, ends here. So, yeah,
that's it. Yes, it's a little bit like
the Pragmatic modeling part gets
foreshadowed or explored in five now
that we're all built up with four. All
right, that's the end of the overview
for 14.
Chapter five is called Message Passing
and Neurobiology. What is your overview
thought on chapter five?
Okay,
I don't know. I have mixed feelings
about this chapter because on one hand,
you see, as far as I understand active
inference, although it originated as,
quote unquote, a unified theory of the
brain, I don't think it's a
neurobiological theory per se.
Of course, there can be some
correlations between neurobiological
components or concepts with active
inference concepts, but it's
not an essential premise
of active inference theory to
provide a comprehensive theory about how
the neurobiology of human brain or
other organisms brain behave
at detailed and neuroanatomical
anatomical level.
But then again, it's nice
to have these kinds of empirical
correlations between the findings of
neurobiology and the active inference
theory. But I
don't think it's one of active inference
central assertions, at least to my
understanding. Well said.
Very interesting framing.
Well, chapter five definitely takes a
very specific system of interest
approach by highlighting one of the most
studied areas, also one of the most
relevant areas, which is mammalian
neuroscience. And the chapter
is going to introduce a few different
motifs in the nervous system and
essentially build up towards figure 5.5,
which is at the end of the chapter, and
5.5 wires together three specific
neural systems that the chapter is going
to focus on work in that area from.
So Ali said it very well,
active inference was built up to in
chapter four. Here is another level or
type of science with assertions or with
representations or mappings to any
specific system. But this is the kind of
modeling that has been built up and done
by Friston Parr Pazulo and others over
the decades, with a focus coming from a
human neuroimaging laboratory setting
a lot of focus and study and attention
and funding and everything on the
mammalian nervous system.
But claims about the nervous system are
not the basis of what active inference
claims or how it's derived.
But this is like an example case study
in neurobiology connecting back to
some of the formalisms that we've just
seen introduced in chapter four. Yeah,
and to add a minor point to what you
just said, I think it's important to
draw attention to the last sentence of
the last paragraph of the first page.
It is important to draw a distinction
between a principle I, e. The
minimization of free energy, and a
process theory about how this principle
may be implemented in a certain kind of
system. So I think this
sentence here frames this chapter
in relation to all the other technical
chapters of this book. So if
every other chapter is about developing,
or at least up to now, was about
developing the principled formalism
of active inference, now, chapter five
provides a kind of preliminary sketch
for the process theory of active
inference, which is obviously far from
an extensive theory. It's just a single
chapter. But then again, it can provide
some important signposts
for anyone who wants to further
investigate this area awesome
free energy. Principle, Bayesian
mechanics, all things in that area are,
on this principle, not responsive to
empirical data. And then the process
theory is about how the principle is
implemented. So the specific generative
models that are made and how well they
map or how well they do in a portfolio
of models that can have very different
goals and assumptions and all of this.
But the process theory implementation
lets us develop hypotheses that are
answerable to empirical data, like what
is the kind of information or
relationship between photons hitting
the retina and changes in activity
in neural systems? And that's an
informational question or can be
abstracted in a way to an informational
question that, it turns out, does have
empirical support and results in
unique explanations and predictions.
That doesn't mean that it always results
in unique explanations and predictions,
but a lot of citations are provided
here. That's what we can explore in
chapter five.
The last paragraph of the first section
describes that they're going to look at
the three different neural systems.
Okay, section 5.2, microcircuits and
messages.
What do you think, Ali? All right.
This chapter begins from how message
passing happens in neurobiological terms
and compare it to the way active
inference frames this message passing
mechanism. And specifically, if we look
at Figure 5.1 and
compare this figure to the ones we've
seen before in chapters
one through four I think it was in
chapter four, we can see some clear
parallels between how this kind of
cortical message passaging happens in
the brain versus how it is framed in
active inference literature. And as we
can see it's clearly inspired
by the neurobiology of the brain. But
then it's important to keep in mind that
it's not a direct one to one
mapping between these two models.
This is just a kind of, I don't know,
an interesting or illuminating,
if you like, parallel to keep in mind to
somehow be a bit more confident about
the viability of the theory we want to
use for message passing and active
inference. Which is to say, it's not
some haphazard theory that's just been
developed for practical reasons. It has
some basis in neurobiology, although
it's not necessarily fully congruent
with every detail of neurobiology.
Great. The specific example is going to
involve this one region of mammalian
cortex tissue that has these six layers,
and there's a ton of neurobiology.
The big takeaway for Figure 5.1 is that
it's possible to graphically lay out
nodes and variables and find some
empirical correspondences, again,
some unique explanations and predictions
in certain cases. And that's
one kind of modeling where it's really
trying to understand and improve the
ability to do correlation and
intervention and counterfactual causal
type analysis with the real system
of interest. Or in a more pedagogical
setting or in a research setting or an
industrial setting, you might sweep
across large families of structures of
models and there's no need to be
grounded to any biological structure at
all. So this is just describing the
specific neuroanatomical research that
really arose out of the imaging work at
UCL and the SPM package. That's where a
lot of this comes from. 5.2.
Yeah, go ahead. Sorry. Just as a side
note, I think watching one of Thomas
Parr's lectures on neurobiology of
active inference, which is available on
YouTube, would really help to understand
the materials of this chapter better.
So I highly recommend watching that one.
Thanks. Figure 5.2
gives a rerendering of a kind of
classical view of a
hierarchical predictive coding system
works. So here abstracting
a layer from the tissue six
layer to just two layers. Here
computational layers now and then
showing how there's hierarchical
communication within a layer, but also
there's signaling within a layer. And
there's a hierarchy in Bayesian
modeling with variables that are higher
order predictions about other variables.
And that's the basis of the predictive
coding architecture. So 5.2
looks at some ways that something that
resonates with the cerebral cortical
architecture enables what might
computationally look like or have some
really strong and explanatory values
in actually relating to computationally
a hierarchical Bayesian model which
could do various general tasks.
All right, 5.3 is motor commands leaving
the prefrontal cortex, going down to the
butterfly looking cross section here.
What is 5.3?
Okay, so 5.3 moves to the
other half of active inference
framework, which is how
it can model the decision making and
ultimately the movement of the agent in
order to minimize the expected
free energy as opposed to variational
free energy that we saw in perceptual
half of active inference. So it
again provides a kind of correlation
or analogy between the structural
neuroanatomy particularly related to
the motor commands and how
it can relates to active inference,
particularly the continuous time active
inference. So we can see that
for the external event or,
I'm sorry, for the external state, we
can take, for example, the
proprioceptive afferent. And then this
proprioceptive afferent acts as a kind
of y for the continuous time active
inference which needs to be processed
in a way to optimize the expected free
energy and how it relates to both
attention and precision.
We will see a bit more detail about
those terms and the relation between
them in chapter eight. But I think
here Section 5.3 provides
a good summary about the general paths
through the motor command systems of
neurobiology. Great. I'd say.
While the previous case study focused on
how the connectivity within and between
the Cortical columns could have a
computational relationship with a
Bayesian hierarchical predictive coding
architecture. The argument of the second
case study is that a continuous input,
continuous output kind of set point
seeking, reflexive motor
behavior with a moving set point with
a descending moving set point enabling
motion by changing ultimately the set
point and enabling variation in
the strategies to reach that set point
through different mechanisms.
This is also describable in a compatible
way that's
a shorter section. Now, section 5.4
subcortical structures.
What would you say about this section?
Okay, so subcortical structures
are very important in the
decision making and the planning
of the agents. So obviously here
we need another kind of analogy between
the way that these plannings
and decision making happen
neuroanatomically with the way that
it's framed in active inference. But
again, we can see it's clearly
based on at least some
of the important elements we've seen
from the previous chapters.
So for example, we saw how policy
is described or how it relates to
outcomes and preference and so on. We
can see those elements are directly
inspired by neuroanatomical structures.
So I
guess that's at
least in my opinion, this section here
5.4 seems a bit more
sketchy in the meaning that it doesn't
go into quite the extensive details
about how those structures
can be compared. But for anyone who
wants to further investigate
these topics, there are some
useful references put on here on pages
93 and 94.
Thanks. Yeah, it's really abbreviated
and overviewed but we
get an interlude from Table 5.1 with
putative roles of neurotransmitters. So
same perspective that we took before on
neuroanatomical functionalism here
directly translates to neurotransmitters
reductionism or essentialism or
something like that. So certainly all
neurotransmitters and molecules, they
play variable roles in different
settings and this
is the neat and Scruffy manifold
all over again. One person might say
well, we need a theory for every
acetylcholine molecule in the world.
They're all in a unique context. And
someone else says all neurotransmitters
are described by one parameter. In this
model I'm getting value from it. So to
me, that's an account. And somewhere in
between is the work in this space,
which is making an attempt to have a
principled and falsifiable approach
to model the computational
aspects of specific regions and contexts
and settings. And so Acetylcholine,
Noradrenaline, Dopamine, and Serotonin
are given a little mini review here.
And so it's not an exhaustive or an
exclusive claim. It's kind of a
provocation from computational and
molecular neuroscience, and people can
look into the papers and also ones that
probably have been published since.
5.6 goes to Continuous and Discrete
Hierarchies, which is graphically
overviewed in Figure 5.5. So what would
you say about this?
Yeah, one interesting thing about this
section is the observation that
our lower level engagement with
the environment can be most
successfully characterized with
continuous time formulations. But as we
go up on the level of
cognitive concepts or at the level of
cognitive hierarchies and we come
to concepts such as, I don't know,
decisions or even beliefs and so on,
we can reach the area that the
discrete time situation would probably
be more efficient to characterize
the behavior of the agent. So this
multiscale structure of active inference
modeling is quite evident in the
way that our message passing
happens in our brain in terms of our
lower level data processing up into
consolidating the higher level cognitive
concepts and ontologies awesome.
Thank you.
To me, Figure 5.5 demonstrates the kind
of whole of body approach that
you could imagine. There's so many
organs and systems and phenomena for
which there aren't specific generative
models. So little can be said about
situations where no generative model has
been articulated, and here's one where
it has. So it gives you also it's kind
of like reading a Drosophila.
Melanogaster review paper relatively.
It's like, this is how much work it
takes to get to this state of knowledge
in an insect. So then in another insect,
do we know less about that insect
empirically and genetically? So consider
this to be what's known to be a lot,
however, also about one of the most
sophisticated or specific cognitive
systems at least we know. So there's
that additional kind of like, self
reflexive aspect to this chapter
that is not a cornerstone of active
inference, but here it's just presented
in a synthetic case study.
Anything else you want to say about
five? Nothing particular
comes to mind. All right.
Okay. Chapter seven is called Active
Inference and Discrete Time. Chapter
seven is the first in a pair of chapters
with chapter eight on Discrete and
Continuous Time. So they're kind of like
two forks of a river that we discussed
in chapter four and before and described
the recipe in chapter six. Now, seven
and eight are kind of like one level
deeper, going from the kind of all of
this group of animals to one level
deeper into its classification scheme on
the way to the specific generative model
for which it's actually given in its
totality. But everything prior to that
is about the learning about its
principles. And this is kind of on the
trunk of the path to discrete time
modeling. Just like chapter eight will
be about continuous time modeling. What
would you add in?
Okay, so I think chapters seven and
eight really helps to understand in
a more practical way how the materials
from particularly chapters one through
five applies in real time situations.
So even if we
somehow didn't get to understand every
details of chapters one through four,
when we come to chapters seven and
eight, I think some
of those uncertainties about our
understandings can be clarified,
at least in a practical sense. So I
believe these two chapters are really
helpful in order to consolidate our
understandings from the previous
chapters. Awesome, well said.
So it's going to involve specifying some
discrete time models.
7.2 goes into perceptual processing and
the general structure of the chapter is
going to walk through a series of
examples that build in complexity where
they first start with perception in 7.2,
introduce decision making and then
describe a few more types of motifs or
cognitive structure or patterns and
also check out step by step and model
stream one where it's built up to in a
different way. So the first example is
I'll let you describe it since it's
musical. Okay.
So yeah, the first example is the
situation in which we try to describe
the performance of an amateur musician
in terms of how we listen
to the performance of an amateur
musicians in terms of the
predictions we get from our
anticipation of the following notes as
opposed to the actual notes that's being
played. So these kinds of anticipatory
reaction listening reaction to
the musician can be successfully
formalized using discrete time active
inference by putting up by
putting together the matrices A for
the states and matrix B for
the transition between the states or the
transition probabilities, which in this
case describes the probability from
going from one note to the other and
obviously the actual sequence that's
been played which can be described with
the matrix d another
point I wanted to mention is
for anyone who has downloaded this
chapter before I don't know, I think
about June or something. I recommend
redownloading it from MIT's website
because they have corrected some of the
typos that was previously present in
this chapter, particularly in Figure
7.2.
Cool. So this graphical model where
a person is listening, this is a general
perceptual Bayesian framing. It's
specified just like
with any other equations. There's a lot
to look into but A indicates the
probability of an outcome given a state.
This is saying if it were all on the
diagonal like an identity matrix, this
is kind of a common motif then states
kind of map to themselves. So in
the context of this model,
a represents the mapping between the
observed note and the underlying hidden
true note and then B.
Describes the transition matrix of how
those change to time. D is the prior
they're specified.
Figure 7.2, do you want to describe it?
All right, so in figure 7.2, or at
least the incomplete version of Figure
7.2 we see here well, at the upper
left part of the picture we
see the beliefs about each
note at each time
step and at upper right we
somehow translate those beliefs into
specific numerical values.
So instead of just assigning some
continuous values, we've simplified
the situation by assigning some discrete
numerical values for each node.
And then the
lower left is supposed to show the
free energy gradients over
time or in other terms the
prediction errors we get from
comparing our predictions with the
actual outcomes. So lastly,
the lower right picture shows in
parallel to the upper right picture,
determines the values of these errors.
So we can see both the
initial or at least initial continuous
assignment and values and then the
further discretizing of the values in
order to get the discrete time situation
or the more tractable discrete time
situations.
Okay, so it's a general passive
inference task where there's priors
about how states are going to change
through time and then there's real data
coming in. So that's the kind of
classical predictive coding video
compression coleman filter Bayesian
setting 7.3 introduces
a key motif which is decision making and
planning as inference. So this is the
idea of having a Bayes graph where the
variables can relate to different
things. There's high composability and
here the idea is that a variable is
going to be proposed that we can do
inference about that describes the
process of decision making or policy
selection. So what would you say about
7.3?
Okay, so 7.3 is obviously
similar to what we saw in chapter
four. And if I'm not mistaken,
even the topology is exactly the same
with that picture we saw previously.
This is the initial setup which
acts also as a review about
how these different components of
palmdp generative models needs to
be described in such situations.
But ultimately the
specific case study we
come across in this section is the
attempt to model the behavior of
a mouse in a teammate of a rat and a
teammate, especially teammates,
containing an aversive stimulus
in one arm and an attractive stimulus on
the other. So this can
act as a kind of toy example to use this
kind of probabilistic modeling to
describe these situations.
Thanks. So that leads us right to figure
7.4. Here's a visualization of the
situation with the rat in this
case where there's a pleasant
and aversive stimuli on
each end of a decision point and there's
also an epistemic opportunity to
receive some information about the
context that the animal is in.
And so that setting is described for
both the case with white on the left,
black on the right and black on the
left, white on the right. And those are
shown in terms of their differences in
the matrices. The explicit specification
of the generative model visualizations
show some of the slices of the B
variable which reflect different
transition probabilities. C represents
the preferences which are expressed over
the observable states,
d reflects the priors on the different
states that need priors.
7.4, what would you say about this?
Okay, so in 7.4, it builds up
on the previous section and adds other
elements that we previously saw in
chapters two and four,
which is how the exact formulation
for expected free energy
can be used sorry, variation free energy
can be used to formulate the trade off
between the information
seeking, or at least between
the epistemic value and information
seeking. So here it uses
again that rad example in a bit more
extended and elaborate form to formulate
the epistemic value of observing a queue
in a given location.
And figure 7.7 is
a representation of this situation.
But another situation that's been,
let me see yeah, in 7.9, another case
study discussed here is
the situation of the psychotic eye
movements because it
is something that can be quite
successfully described or characterized
in terms of information seeking versus
the epistemic value. And the situation
here is let me see.
Yeah. Shown visually in Figure
7.9, which clearly shows
how our visual psychotic
eye movement can be described
in such a way as to kind of trace the
trajectory of our eye movement among
different regions of the visual space
and how the information we gather from a
given region can
affect the subsequent
trajectories of our psychotic eye
movements.
That's basically the
main premise of this section, I guess.
Nice. Great.
7.5, what would you say
about it?
Okay, so 7.5 again
adds another dimension to the previous
formulations, and this time, we get to
update the generative models by learning
and the so
the generative models for this situation
is a bit more complicated than the
previous ones because it now needs
to account for a mechanism
or a way to update the matrices we had
before. So in the previous situations we
didn't account for learning
per se, but here we directly
update our general sorry, the word
update can be confusing. Here we get to
somehow improve our generative
models to accommodate for these updating
accounts.
The situation here or the case study
here, which somehow elucidate
the way that the learning can
be accounted for with these models
is again a toy example of
a creature in a simple
world of black and
white tiles which kind of tries
to find a path to reach
a given destination, a certain
destination. So it is
more complicated than the situation we
had for the Rat example because it only
had simple trajectories
that needed to traverse.
But here the creature, or the
agent in this case needs to do
lots more learning and information
seeking and so on. So all the previous
elements is kind of combined
in this example and it's a really good
example to see how the different
components of active inference can be
connected to each other. Nice and 76
hierarchical or deep inference. First,
a box 7.3 interlude on structure
learning, boxed off topic and a lot to
say, but structure learning broadly
refers to learning the structure about a
model using the same types of methods
that you might to do inference on, for
example, a more observable sensor
data reading, something like that.
This section works towards the idea
of nested inference or multiscale
modeling. What would you say about
figure 712?
Okay, so again, this situation is,
I think, the most complex situations of
this chapter, which builds up from the
previous sections. And this time it adds
another layer to accommodate for
the inferences that happen in different
time steps. So in this case we have
multi time or multiscale inference and
learning happening both at
the levels of learning and at the levels
of information seeking. So this
is represented in figure
seven, point twelve, which represents
how kind of this fractal
generative model can be seen as a
component in this
multiscale bigger generative or
as a kind of leaf in this bigger
generative model. So it can be seen
as a lower level
inference happening at the leaf level,
going up to the hierarchy and
influencing sorry,
collaborating on the whole process of
learning and inference at the higher
level.
Yeah, I guess that somehow
summarizes this figure. So if you have
anything to add, that's great.
It's an example of the composability of
generative models. What we've
talked about and had Toby Sinclair Smith
describe as as the compositional
cognitive cartography and just what
kinds of connectors can and can't you do
and how can that motif that the discrete
time model introduces and then the rest
of these features, including action and
learning and so on, get layered in on
top? What can you do with that?
713 gives another example.
Do you want to say anything about it or
maybe continue on? Yeah, so the case
study here is the example of linguistic,
I mean, language learning through
reading. So not language learning,
maybe just what happens sentence
comprehension reading. Yeah, in
comprehension. So what happens when
reading in an anticipatory
way the words that
comes each after the other. So why
this kind of situation can be most
successfully characterized with this
kind of modeling because it involves
different scales of learning and
comprehension, both at the level of at
the level of somehow observing the
letters and then going onto the words
and then word groups and so on. So,
yeah, that's really interesting way to
again combine all of those elements into
a single unified model to see how
those different timescales, slow and
fast timescales operate together
to build this more encompassing
model of more encompassing generative
model of the situation.
Great. Any closing thoughts on seven?
Nothing particular now, thanks. All
right, next chapter is chapter eight,
which is going to go into the continuous
time.
It's all
right. Chapter eight is called active
inference in continuous time. Begins
with that timeless quote, everything
flows, nothing stands still. So what
would you say about chapter eight? All
right, so this chapter probably
is my most favorite chapter in the book
because of my own personal interest in,
I don't know, process materialism and
so on.
Chapter seven acts
as a really good starting point for
anyone who wants to develop the discrete
time situations to model discrete time
situations within active inference
framework. But in chapter eight,
we kind of get to model
a bit more interesting or let's say
more involving situations.
And they're not necessarily kind
of toy examples we saw at least at the
beginning of chapter seven. So
obviously, as the title suggests, this
chapter deals with the continuous time
situation. So in that case we'll
need to maybe at this point refresh
our memory about what continuous time
situation involves by reading the
relevant parts, reading or reviewing
relevant parts of chapter four.
In chapter four, we saw that the
generative model for continuous time
situation derives
from the Edo's Stochastic
calculus in terms of putting
the whole process into two
elements of Stochastic equations, one of
which is the actual states,
the condition of actual states or
the behavior of the actual states. And
the other one is the randomness that
we need to account for in each real
time continuous time situations. So
that's what we get here in equation 8.1.
And then building up from that equation,
it generalizes that equation to involve
the functionals of G and F instead of
just the
single valued functions of GNF. So then
we get to put that
into the situation that can be
used for describing the behavior of
dynamical systems, which is a very well
known situation to use
these kinds of Stochastic equations.
And it's widely studied how those
kinds of dynamics can be characterized,
especially in recent Bayesian mechanics
paper by Dalton Saktivetevel
and others. And then it
gets to some more specific examples such
as Lotgobal Terra dynamics and
synchronicity and so on, in order
to show how these kinds of dynamics
can be elaborated upon and
can be generalized and
enables them to characterize more
complex situations.
That's a really short and brief overview
of the whole chapter. Maybe we
can talk about a bit more details as we
go through it. Great, well said.
Well, I'm sure for another day the
philosophical implications of eight,
Seven and Eight and High Road and Low
Road and all these other parts of the
textbook. Great topics. I agree. I would
see chapter eight as demonstrating
continuity with some classical
continuous time modeling motifs from a
few different areas of dynamical systems
science, which is applied in many,
many fields. But these are some classic
examples. So figure 8.1 goes a
little bit more into depth or at least
into more formalism detail about exactly
what we saw in chapter five with the
spinal reflex arc with the
proprioceptive data coming in and then a
differential being calculated with the
set point which reflects a descending
prediction from a decision making layer.
And that can be viewed as this kind of
mechanics that plays out in a phase
space in continuous time, like a spring
moving around with someone making a
certain path within a tractor and a
spring being dragged around something in
that area. Box 8.1
goes into a very fascinating topic. Do
you want to describe it?
Well, it's maybe one of the
most thought provoking pages
of the whole book. And if I remember
correctly, in all of the cohorts, this
particular box always
gives rise to lots of questions because
of some of the interesting and at least
initially counterintuitive claims
here. But I don't want
to spoil it.
But as a kind of spoiler alert,
it kind of gets to
really interesting, but alas,
very brief discussion about the
comparing these terms precision,
attention and sensory attenuation and
the relation and similarities and
difference between these three terms and
how understanding each of them is
essential to understanding the other
ones. But as I said,
it's a really interesting topic which
gives rise to lots of discussions and
I believe it's one of those topics
that's worth looking a bit
more looking into in some
other literature as well. Great. Well
said. What a cliffhanger. Next they go
to a classic model family called
Lockable Terra. These dynamics inherit
from characterizations of predator prey
dynamics in ecology. So it's kind of a
classical ecology model shown in Figure
8.2 on the top. It's actually the
ecosystem model plants, herbivores and
carnivores which follow different kinds
of oscillatory trends in continuous
time. And so that also has enabled it to
be applied for other so called
winnerless competitions. And that
relates to topics like neural Darwinism
and also neural dynamics where things
have kind of oscillatory relationships
with each other which are being modeled
as a continuous time underlying process
with a lot of measurement, noise and
discretization through space and time.
Those are the kinds of algorithms that
SPM explores more and there's lock of
Voltera and a lot of other dynamical
systems theory in SPM. So active
inference kind of adds action and more
to what was laid out from a pure
dynamical systems theory in SPM.
Here. It really is just showing the
ecology example and how you can project
if you have three different species,
you can think about that motion in a
cube or tetrahedron, and then you could
project onto kind of like looking
at a lower dimensional manifold relating
just two of the three species. And that
evinces this kind of oscillatory but
also moving behavior that gets connected
in Figure 8.3 to neurobiology.
What would you say about this?
Okay, so here in Figure 8.3
we see some applications of a
lot of altera dynamics. So the
left column here represents
what happens in
eye blink conditioning. So of
course here we need to account
for the expected
states of
the sequences of events that happens in
the eye blinking. So the upper
left figure shows the expectations in
terms of time. And then the
parallel right hand side equation,
sorry, right hand side figures
shows the Lotka
volterra systems that is applied in
the handwriting situation. So, as we can
see, although the mathematical
technology is the same, or at least the
modeling technology is the same, the
outcome of each situation varies
drastically in two distinct
two distinct neurobiological behavior,
not neurobiological, but biological
behavior. So, yeah, we can see how
the same modeling framework can give
rise to different outcomes
based on what parameters
needs to be optimized, what parameters
are selected for the modeling, and so
on. So I believe it's a quite
interesting example to compare
handwriting and a blinking together and
how those can be compared to
each other using the lotkobal
thermodynamics great. Thank you.
Box 8.2 gives a variant on
the learning here presented with the
formalism for continuous models. Kind of
a technical aside, section 8.4
is about generalized synchrony. So
figure 8.4 is going to visualize one of
the classic dynamical systems, which is
the Lorenz attractor. So what would you
say about this figure? Okay,
so this section is truly
interesting because when one thinks
of active inference, probably the
first situations that comes to mind is
the situations in which we have quite
well defined probability distributions
for different parameters. But as we can
see here in Section 8.4,
actually some of the formalism of active
inference can be successfully used
to characterize even chaotic systems,
and in particular the way in which two
chaotic systems can be synchronized with
each other. So this is a classic
example of chaotic Lorentz system
and it draws
upon from some of Professor Prison's
earlier work on birdsong synchrony.
And as a side note, any literature
before 2016 is considered
earlier history in active inference
literature because it evolves quite
rapidly.
This kind of synchrony between two
chaotic systems can be interpreted
as providing evidence or even,
let's say, a way to model a
kind of primitive theory of mind,
in the sense that how exactly can we
understand or two
agents can trace each other's
trajectories without any
I mean, engaging in any direct
exchange of observations between their
internal and external states. So, yeah,
that's a really good example, and I
believe one of the most interesting
examples of how active inference can
even account for these kinds of
behavior. And the rest
of the section goes into the details of
how this kind of synchrony between
multiscale Lorentz systems can happen
and how can we formulate it
mathematically in terms of continuous
time active inference.
Awesome. And there's been more recent
work on Markov Blankets and Stochastic
chaos. But the Bird example is a classic
8.5 goes into hybrid discrete and
continuous models. So this could be kind
of like an in between chapter of seven
and eight. But now that we've been
introduced to the pure form of discrete
and the pure form of continuous models
here shown that that composability
extends to so called hybrid models where
here the lower level visually is
using the continuous time formalism and
the higher level is describing a little
line added here, the discrete time
formalism. And this was the similar
structure described by the authors of
the paper. Active inference does not
contradict folk psychology where they
described this lower level as motor
active inference which was closely
allied with the spinal arc reflex shown
above. And then this higher level they
called decision active inference because
in that case it was referring to a
discrete decision. And so they used that
kind of basic motif of continuous
activity or continuous time modeling at
the more peripheral aspects of a
cognitive entity and like Ali said,
more discretization and hybridization
as well at higher levels of the
cognitive modeling.
And that type of an architecture here,
instead of describing who wants the ice
cream cone, I believe here it's going to
be a mixed or a hybrid model that is
going to call back the Icicade system
where there's a fixed point that
is able to be moved as a set point,
and then there's a continuous time
icicade that pursues the new fixed
point. And so that's analogous to a new
set point or fixed point being specified
from the top down muscle command about a
new location for a muscle followed by
movement towards it. This is a muscular
activity that is realizing that but not
in the elbow coming away from the hot
stove. This is about the eye circading
to an epistemic foraging location
specified by top down hierarchical
systems. 8.3 describes little technical
aside on mixture of Gaussian gaussian
mixture models, kind of a technical
modeling note. And 8.6 closes
it says it's a huge topic and much has
been left out. And so they list in Table
8.1 key advances in continuous time
models. And those areas are synthetic
birdsong, ocular, motor delays,
conditioned reflexes, smooth pursuit,
eye movements, psychosis illusions,
cicades action, observation attention,
hybrid models and self organization.
And that's chapter eight. What else
would you say? And also what would you
kind of lead someone to in the
philosophical implications of eight?
Because it sounds kind of cool.
Okay, well,
the case of continuous time active
inference,
I think it leads to really
interesting questions both in terms of
philosophical questions and also more
practical modeling questions about
what parameters needs to be accounted
for and so on. And as I said,
I believe it's a more
interesting way of it's not
interesting, but at least more involved
way of doing active inference modeling.
But one thing that one
of the philosophical questions that
Mahault and I have explored in our
paper is how the
processes,
ontological processes can
philosophically described using FEP
assertions in terms of their intraaction
with the environment in
which they co constitute themselves.
And we don't necessarily distinguish
between the internal and the external
states. So one obvious example of this
is that generalized synchrony example
that we saw in this chapter in which we
don't necessarily distinguish between
which of the birds act as the
agent and which one is the environment
or the vice versa. So these kind of co
constitution of the environment and the
agent which gives rise to the
partitioning of state space through
markup blanket is one of the
interesting philosophical
points that I think needs to be
elaborated a bit. More using
some of the recent advances in
philosophy, such as the tools that's
been developed in New Materialism School
or some other philosophical approaches.
But yeah, these kinds of what exactly
gives rise to emergence? What is the
ontological status of emergent
properties and so on, are some of the
burning questions for many philosophers
today. And I believe active inference,
and particularly continuous time active
inference, provides a clear,
precise mathematical formalism,
even if not to answer
these questions, but at least to explore
it in a more rigorous and practical
way, and also practical
and attractable way. So this
is the area that I believe philosophy
and science are beautifully intertwined
into a coherent view of not only
the phenomena of interest, but even
about the whole world.
Wow.
Pretty cool. Yeah. A lot to say about
that topic. After completing
chapters seven and eight, you've seen
the kind of two major branches or two
major motifs of just one kind of
modeling. But these kind of models have
so many different forms that that's why
it's such a hands on process to specify
the generative model in chapter six and
fit it with data in chapter nine. Those
are all what's required. And that's kind
of the last mile of where these
discussions about general motifs gets
you. But also playing with these
pedagogical models can be really helpful
because it will help you understand the
basic patterns and relationships and
start to see different patterns in the
graphical models and know from there
what levels of technical processes can
be kind of coarse grained over.
All right.
Okay. Well, that's it. I guess next
time we will do probably 910
and maybe something else. All right,
I'll end it now. Thanks, Ali. Thank you.
Bye.